Okay.
Politic.
We have talked about how we now live in
a world where every day there is less
poverty and people are able to live
better.
Lives are changed.
That is even reaching the most
unprotected region in the world.
Sub Saharan Africa.
Okay.
We talked about the African lions and
paid special attention,
so in cases like Rwanda,
however,
we still need to talk about when and why
this region of the world,
which so many considered hopelessly
destitute began to change.
Sure.
Well,
that is precisely what we are going to
talk about in this video.
That's ams.
What we can expect in the upcoming
years.
Four years talking about Africa has
men's talking about extreme poverty,
natural disasters and all kinds of
conflicts and in a way things are still
about,
wait,
see?
No.
More or less than half.
Yes.
Half of all the people who suffer from
extreme poverty in the world live in
these sub Saharan African region.
We're talking about 400 million people
have also like this isn't surprising
either.
Yeah.
Facing the largest humanitarian crisis
since the creation of the United Nations
in 1945 now,
more than 20 million people across four
countries face starvation and famine.
Stephen O'Brien,
the UN under secretary general for
humanitarian affairs.
Do you do all of this?
I'm sure nobody has the stranger to
those Ngo campaigns seeking to raise
funds for all kinds of humanitarian
catastrophes in Africa.
You're probably also familiar with
governments allocating billions of
dollars each year to official
development assistance.
In fact,
government aid is as high as it's ever
been.
Every year the African guns and receives
about $50 billion and this,
it's been going on for them
decades.
However,
the truth is that for years,
all of this money,
it didn't help very much.
Let's take a look at,
for example,
the 1919
yes
Wallington national aid in this area of
the world amounts to tens of billions.
What do you think happens with poverty?
Do you think it decreased?
Well,
no.
None of that happen.
Sure.
1990 and 1998 it's poverty levels went
from 55% to 58
is that,
well,
how could this be?
You might ask.
Well because intentions are one thing
but reality is ready difference.
Some experts claim that's it.
For years,
official aid weakens local print
juices.
Evidence
overwhelmingly demonstrates that aid to
Africa has made the poor
poorer and growth slower.
Dambisa Moyo an economist and the author
of dead aid.
Why aid is not working and how there is
a better way for Africa.
For example,
in Tanzania it was cheaper to buy
subsidized the milk from the European
Union oven from local producers.
However,
with the beginning of a new century,
suddenly everything began to change
for great change.
Suddenly
only when Africa seemed helpless,
everything began to change.
With the beginning of the 21st century,
statistics absolutely turns around.
Since the year 2000 and extreme poverty
has dropped by almost 40% average life
expectancy has grown by more than 10
years.
Infant mortality has decreased to less
than half the same as happens with HIV
infections in children as well.
Virtually any other
statistic.
If we look good,
the economy will be able to see how
between 2000 and 2015 sub Saharan
African countries excluding South
Africa,
which has a bit of a peculiar case as
we've seen on visual politic previously
grew by an average of 6% which is more
than twice,
for example,
Latin America.
Another great indicator of how things
are changing is tourism.
Okay?
Yup.
Tourism.
You heard that right?
The tourism sector has some particular
characteristics that reveal a lot of
information.
On the one hand,
this sector has great transformational
power for the poorest because it's very
labor intensive and on the other hand
can we need to take into account so that
people don't vacation in countries that
are at war or a famine or have
epidemics.
It's just not a nice holiday.
When this industry improves in the
poorest countries,
it is usually a good indicator that
things are improving as a whole.
What if we see the data?
We might be quite surprised because this
sector has been growing as an average
annual rate of no less than 9% for 20
years.
That is two full decades of nearly
double digit growth.
Yes,
it does seem as if things are really
moving forward,
which
bought at this point in the video,
you might be wondering something because
I certainly am.
What on earth happens to cause such a
change?
Well,
have a look at this graph because it
really gives a clue what,
what exactly led to this miracle.
Well,
that's have a look at that.
Okay.
Airing for takeoff
things
drive change,
but we will now see how three particular
events in Africa began to change
probably permanently.
This continence reality,
the first one it was remittances.
See in Africa the population grows very
quickly,
which along with the terrible living
conditions has led.
Many Africans do immigrates to rich
countries in the past few decades.
Today,
these people send tens of billions of
dollars home every year.
This money is used in local markets or
to set up businesses.
These are what we call remittances ans
they are actually much more important
than developmental eight seconds and
very importantly,
in March of 2000 the u s Congress
finally approved a law that had been
promoted by Bill Clinton in his last
years in office.
It's called the African Growth and
Opportunity Act.
This is basically a law that establishes
a preferential trade agreements that
eliminates terrorists and reduces
barriers to trade for thousands and
thousands of products from sub Saharan
Africa.
See,
since this agreement was approved,
we can see that between 2000 and 2016
which went exactly the most prosperous
years,
have a trade between the United States
in sub Saharan Africa multiplied two and
a half times,
which means a 6% growth every year and
third and perhaps the key to everything.
There's China.
Yup.
Yeah.
Have the rights.
In 2001 China,
it joins the World Trade Organization as
became something of a factory to the
world.
Well,
what has happened since then has been
quite impressive.
China's huge grief has lifted tens of
millions of people out of poverty,
both in China and in Africa.
Government of China and that was when in
the honest thing,
Ethiopia's industrialization and on
supporting the yes,
great vision to become Africa's
manufacturing.
Oh,
to explain myself yet the Asian giants,
gigantic grief has increased this
country's demands for all kinds of
products,
raw materials,
food,
manufacturing,
everything.
Well,
many African countries took advantage of
this opportunity since the year 2000 to
trade between China and Africa has
multiplied by no less than the 17 times
representing an annual growth rate of
almost 20% since 2009 China is already
by far the continent's largest trading.
Yeah.
Partner.
There's not only that,
the Chinese,
as we mentioned here have also been
investing a lot of money all over the
world and Africa is certainly no
exception.
Yeah.
In 2016 four out of every 10 euros that
Farhan is invested in,
Africa came from China.
Today more than 10,000 Chinese companies
are doing business on the African
continent is can I sleep?
Private companies that work in all kinds
of industries and that number one,
it just keeps running.
Yes.
My friends.
This is how Africa has managed to start
turning the statistics around the
greatest catalyst for this entire
change.
It wasn't some kind of miracle and it
didn't have much to do with
developmental aid.
This change was driven by trade and
investments and Africans themselves seem
to see it very clearly and if you don't
believe me,
I'll take a look at this.
African countries are forging ahead to
complete negotiations for continental
free trade area between 55 countries by
early next year.
The idea adopted by the African Union in
2012 is to create a single market which
includes the free movement of goods,
services and people.
Yes,
that's right.
Africa is working to expand the trade to
every corner of the continents.
Not all countries are developing
equally,
but this is quite normal and then all
parts of the world following the Asian
Star
points,
we need to ask ourselves the question,
can we really dream of Africa's final
takeoff?
See,
I suspect that many of you are probably
thinking right now.
Well everything you say in visual
politic is very nice,
but it isn't usually what really
happens.
Well,
yes,
in Africa,
it's absolutely true that all countries
that are doing well and there are
countries that are not doing well,
but you know what?
That's true,
but it's also really normal.
See,
it may sound shocking today,
but in the 1950s Asia was this poor as
Africa.
I mean today we can look at cities like
Shanghai,
Hong Kong,
Taipei.
It makes it really hard to imagine that
these places will.
One is pork.
The when South Korea or Taiwan began to
grow,
they weren't richer than Ghana or
Senegal for example,
and China,
India and Vietnam era.
Of course,
way poorer.
Okay,
can absolutely draw some really
interesting ideas from this because
Asian countries didn't grow all at once
and they didn't grow all together.
While Korea,
Singapore,
Japan,
and Taiwan grew.
Other countries such as China,
Indonesia,
and India remains in mass
poverty.
They weren't exactly democratic models.
South Korea and Taiwan were under hard
dictatorships until very recently.
Singapore is in a similar state.
China,
well,
what can I say in shorts and lots of
poverty,
some more advanced countries with
others.
Further behind is plenty of
dictatorships.
Essentially what we're seeing in Africa
today wasn't so different from what was
happening in Asia just 50 years ago.
Ready
for takeoff?
Yes.
Things in Africa are changing after the
10 countries that are apparently growing
the most in 2017 five are in Africa.
If we
take a look at the latest to doing
business reports,
the wells bank indicator for measuring
how easy it is to do business in certain
economies,
we can see the towns of the 10 countries
that have improved the most for are also
African.
True poverty here is still very high and
these countries are facing a difficult
challenge.
Indeed,
the large population growth on the
continent is actually going to multiply
in the upcoming decades.
However,
the good news is that everything
indicates,
but thanks to trade and international
investments.
Africa is finding its way and it's maybe
once and for all is ready for takeoff,
but I would see what town do you think
that Africa will emulate,
the developments that Asia has had in
recent decades?
Well,
leave us your answer in the comment
section below as well as in this survey
because I really hope you've this video
do hit that like button if you did,
and do not forget to subscribe for brand
new videos from this channel every
Monday and Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check it off,
friends at the reconsider media podcast
if they provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thank you for watching.